Film Courage: Why not pitch Netflix and get
them to do an upcoming project?
Brad Sykes, Writer/Director: I doubt I would
ever get in the room with them?
I mean…I’m just being honest.
I don’t know how I would get in the room
with them?
It’s weird in this business too and this
is the honest truth is you know I am sure
and I’m not saying it was easy for The Duffer
Brothers with STRANGER THINGS but it did probably
help that they hadn’t done a whole lot when
they pitched that.
What happens in this business is it’s kind
of a double-edged sword if you start to do
things and you have a track record and you
made X number of movies well okay that’s
great because it shows you can do this and
you’ve done it more than once and obviously
you’ve got some kind of track record skills
and so on.
But for some people depending on what type
of movies you make and in my case it’s horror
movies, that’s a stigma, it stigmatizes
you and then most people think that’s all
that they can do, that’s all that guy knows
how to do.
Let’s just throw a name out there Wes Craven
on an obviously way bigger level.
He struggled with that his entire career.
That’s why he made the movie with Meryl
Streep [1999 - MUSIC OF THE HEART] because
he was tired of making horror, he wanted to
make other things.
Most horror directors want to make other types
of movies, they just don’t get to.
George Romero had plenty of things he wanted
to do, Wes Craven…they all do…John Carpenter…all
of them.
But they are generally not going to get it
and I’m talking about major people here,
they are not going to get it because their
track record says “he makes this type of
film.”
My track record says I make these types of
films and I don’t think that Netflix would
care about that.
I think they would see that as a negative.
Maybe if I’d only made one short [film]
they might be interested in having a meeting
with me, a short that was very hot let’s
just say that played at some major festival.
And that’s not because I don’t have any
ideas for things or I don’t have ideas that
could be expanded to TV series so yeah…
Film Courage: So having been here in the 1990’s
and then entering a new era where there is
going to be younger people in charge, do you
find you have a harder time telling you no
than Get Xer’s or people in another decade
where it seems like it was okay to be a little
more blunt?
Now we are very sensitive and we’re dancing
around everybody’s feelings and nobody wants
to tell anybody no.
But then they are not telling you the truth
because…and I’m seeing a lot of that and
maybe it’s just better for people to tell
you no.
Brad: Yeah, there is…it’s because of so
much online communication there is the classic
no response, sort of the ghosting or whatever
that people do where they just want to move
away from the situation or say no or whatever,
they just won’t do anything.
I guess like no response is okay whatever
that is.
I don’t know I mean we are pretty straightforward
with people like we are very straightforward
in auditions.
We are very straightforward in meetings about
when we’re interviewing crew that doesn’t
mean that things are not going to still come
up later.
Sometimes it doesn’t matter how much you
talk until you are blue in the face and impress
something upon someone they either aren’t
listening to you or they’ve got an agenda
or they just decide that they’ve got another
idea later on.
That can all happen.
You have to be prepared for that.
We just try to be as straightforward as possible
and what other people do we can’t really
say.
But if we get a bad vibe off of somebody or
a non-committal vibe or whatever, we just
move on.
There is a lot of moving on you do in this
business…a ton of it, too much.
And sometimes it happens way quicker than
you think it will.
But that is something else you need to get
used to if you’re going to have a career
on any level is just get used to change and
new faces and kind of self-starting and coming
up with things almost every film is your first
film I’m sure you’ve heard that before.
I feel like I’ve felt that way many times
that I’m trying to pitch something to some
people and I’m going why do I even have
to do this?
I’ve got over 20 features…because…because
that is just how this business is.
People always want, you’ve always got to
prove yourself to somebody in some way, some
more than others but.
Film Courage: Knowing that does it make it
less stressful?
Knowing that you have to self-start again
and then you go okay I am back here again.
Brad: It’s annoying I mean I’ll be honest
with you, it’s annoying.
Of course because you know there are other
people who don’t have to do that, there
are I mean on a higher tier there are people
who don’t have to do that.
But there are an alarming number of accomplished
people who do so that makes it a little easier
to take I guess when you know that some of
your heroes still have to put on a dog and
pony show with investors or whatever.
I don’t know I mean we try to take things,
we try to be as calm as we can over time.
That’s one thing that Josephina [Sykes]
try to sort of learn with some of these experiences
that you can get very heated over these little
situations sometimes with film.
That’s probably something I would tell anybody
really is a lot of times it’s not a big
a deal as you think it is.
If it’s an editing issue, if it’s a sound
issue, if it’s a certain shot you don’t…believe
me, it’s not as big a deal as you think
it is.
Sometimes you can get very fixated on these
types of things and you can get very stressed
about this stuff.
It’s not even about personality.
Sometimes it’s technical things too.
You just try to be as calm as you can on those
types of situations.
Questions For The Viewers: Do you think having
too many credits can hurt you in the film
industry?